fait de forme à l'épaule zone le dernier
cd 2 for my people la belle de kool shen
qui est mon invité ce soir bien alors on
va faire une promo bien comme il faut là
comme on fait la télévision alors
d'abord une question qui va faire un
malheur sur les 15-34 kool shen vous
rêvez la double casquette de producteur
et de chanteur est il possible de porter
une double casquette à l'envers
j'en mets une devant et une derrière
s'aplanissent un peu l'interview mcm là
alors c'est important que se disent que
rencontre son public
bah ouais un moment donné d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça qu'on va partir sur la
scène pour faire une tournée
voyons voir les gens de près ayé journée
bientôt huawei secor fin novembre début
décembre normalement si tout va bien
alors quel message voudriez-vous
transmettre à travers ce disque les
questions assez les questions mc alger 9
et demi avant d'accord pourrait demander
aux différents artistes on est on est
une pléiade dessus donc on fait chacun
peu envie de véhiculer ces histoires moi
je suis pas trop dictateur dans
l'histoire donc chacun fait son truc
mais sache qu'il ya un véhicule et c'est
pas un message collectif quoi j'ai envie
de balancer son truc vous écouter
l'album c'est pas une secte qua non
attention la question de vote suisse
c'est un album de maturité vu que c'est
le premier de formats people ce serait
prétentieux de dire qui est spécial ce
soit sur la maturité
vous avez une anecdote sympa à raconter
sur l'album ouais on enregistre
régulièrement bourg et donc
pas mal de trucs qui se font pas dans
les temps quoi voilà vous êtes fier
maintenant kool shen de faire partie de
la grande famille de la chanson
française
j'ai pas l'impression d'en faire partie
jusqu'à présent il faut bien dire ça
cool vous dit merci à la vie aujourd'hui
c'est toi tu dis quoi moi je dis merci à
la vie mais je le dis un peu comme toi
alors toujours dans une impasse plaindre
non plus
yann
qui
fazila eberhard c'est bien c'est bien
séduire
tora
m